hallo herzlich willkommen in meine
torten welt heute zeige ich euch wie man
muss ja ball am 8
und das rezept dazu und die anleitung
findet ihr auf www punkt muss - chocolat
punkt.de und was ihr an zutaten benötigt
das zeige ich euch jetzt ihr benötigt
200 gramm zarter schokolade vier eier
200 gramm schlagsahne und 50 gramm
zucker bei den eiern bisher darauf
achten dass sie ganz frisch sind weil es
ihr ruf verwendet und bei der schokolade
müsst ihr darauf achten dass ihr
mindestens darf mit der schokolade nehmt
also mit 50 prozent kakaoanteil
noch besser ist natürlich schokolade mit
einem höherem kakaoanteil deswegen nehme
ich heute eine packung kaffee schokolade
und eine packung schokolade mit 60
prozent kakaoanteil vollmilchschokolade
solltet ihr nicht verwenden die hat
nämlich einen zu geringen kakaoanteil
und dadurch würde die schon muster
schokolade schokolade genug schmecken
zuerst müsst ihr zu schokolade fein
hacken
wer möchte kann auch einen mixer
schmeißen das geht dann auch viel
schneller
die kleine die schokolade jetzt umso
schneller schmilzt später im wasserbad
als nächstes gibt ihr dann die
schokolade in eine kleine schüssel und
schmerzt sie über dem wasserbad das
wasserbad darf aber nicht zu heiß sein
wenig schokolade dann vollständig
geschmolzen ist nehmen diese aus dem
wasserbad heraus und lasst sie abkühlen
als nächstes nimmt ihr euch dann die
vier eier und trennt sie nachweisen dass
einer kommt ihnen eure große
rührschüssel und das eiweiß in die
kleinere schüssel
zum einen gibt jetzt zwei bis drei
esslöffel heißes wasser mit dazu und
unter rühren lass dich an den zucker
einrieseln lassen aber etwa die hälfte
sogar noch für das eiweiß hybrid in der
zwischenzeit schlag ich ihn schon mal
die sahne steif und schnell sie kühl
danach nimmt ihr euch das eiweiß und
schlag das auch steif und kurz vor ende
gebt ihr noch den zucker mieter zu und
stellt das eiweiß auch kühl
schallt dann die rührmaschine mit dem
eigelb auch eine stufe runter und gibt
die geschmolzene schokolade ganz langsam
mit dazu und passt gut drauf auch dass
sie die maschine gut durchrühren sonst
habt ihr später noch mal gebrauchen an
geblieben
danach wird noch das eiweiß und die
sahne unter die schoko massa gewogen das
müsst ihr ganz vorsichtig machen und
darauf achten dass wir nicht zu viel
luft aus der wasser raus schreibt
die fertige creme fühlt ihr dann in
kleine schüsseln oder eine große klappe
so wie ich und deckt sie dann ab und
danach kommt sie in den kühlschrank
die masse muss jetzt für mindestens 46
stunden in den kühlschrank und danach
zeige ich euch wie ich sie heute
servieren
wie ihr seht was die herstellung viel
einfacher als man denkt und wenn jetzt
das rezept zum ausdrucken wollt dann
schaut doch mal auf der most chocolat
seite vorbei der linke zu verlinken den
meiner infobox und das war's dann auch
schon für heute ich wünsche euch viel
spaß beim nachmachen und bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss